the nature of Faith the power of grief
and how to kill a monster you can't even
see Bird Box Barcelona raises some big
questions and its ending opens up plenty
of possibilities for future sequels
warning spoilers ahead
before getting into the events of bird
box Barcelona it makes sense to do a
recap of some details from the first
film that are crucial to the new story
Staying Alive is immensely challenging
in the world of bird box survivors are
forced to blindly Traverse areas to
avoid seeing the creatures those who are
lured into looking at the creatures have
one of two Fates either they kill
themselves or they're manipulated into
becoming a Seer to carry out the
creature's requests even if survivors
manage to keep their blindfolds on the
creatures can mimic the voices of lost
loved ones or anyone close to their
victims to try and convince them to take
their blindfolds off in Barcelona the
creature's power is even deadlier but
they face even savvier survivors there's
a greater focus on putting blindfolds on
animals in Barcelona since the creatures
can affect them too and there are new
kinds of blinders the survivors use like
Sebastian's blacked out goggles more new
survival tactics utilize sounds and dogs
to alert groups of the creature's
presence however not even the best
survivors can be prepared for the
arrival of a Seer a faction that's also
much craftier and deadlier than we see
in the original Bird Box
Sebastian is a dedicated Seer at the
start of bird box Barcelona he's shown
to be capable of devastating and
unpredictable actions against
unsuspecting survivors he has no place
for mercy in his mission to save people
and is especially dangerous to a new
group he comes across as the survivors
try to make it to a possible safe haven
up in the mountains Sebastian Works
towards sabotaging them he lies to them
about everything and lets the group's
dogs loose to deprive them of their
canine guides however he's not able to
stay under the radar for long as English
Survivor Claire is able to uncover the
truth about him but as Sebastian travels
with the group he begins to question his
purpose and whether his actions are
really saving people soon he's unable to
ignore the Carnage around him and begins
to have a change of heart as he
remembers what life was like before
becoming a Seer his time with Claire and
a young German girl named Sophia starts
to clear his mind of the creature's
control over him it's why Sebastian
eventually breaks from his Seer control
and decides to help Claire and Sophia
reach safety just as his leader who
killed his daughter years prior
confronts the survivors
once Sebastian rejects his status as a
Seer he does everything in his power to
get Claire and Sophia to the aerial
Tramway that will take them to the
supposed Safe Haven in the mountains
however father Esteban and his fellow
seers are hot on their tail It
ultimately leads Sebastian to send
Claire and Sophia forward so he can keep
the Sears at Bay while Sebastian is able
to create a blockade to the Tramway by
making a car explode it's not enough to
keep the power of the creatures and
Esteban from manipulating him Esteban
and a hallucination of Anna continue to
try and restore Sebastian's Faith but
Sebastian remains firm and no longer
believes that God would want this why
did you abandon us
Because deep down I always knew that you
killed her however this doesn't stop
Esteban now masquerading as the
hallucination of Anna from miraculously
walking over the Flaming car towards
Sebastian to prove his independence from
the creatures Sebastian charges Anna and
ends up stabbing Esteban through the gut
unfortunately Esteban pulls Sebastian
onto the metal rod as well which
punctures his torso Sebastian decides to
not fight back to keep Esteban trapped
they both end up dying as a result of
Sebastian's sacrifice while it's sad to
see the reformed Seer fall his wishes to
reunite with his family and finally do
the right thing are fulfilled while
Sebastian makes his sacrifice Clara and
Sophia try to make their escape they
nearly meet a quick death from the Tower
falling apart and seems stuck with no
way to power the lift from their
location Claire realizes that she has to
alert the people on the other side that
they need help by ringing a bell but the
sound draws the attention of one of the
creatures when it arrives it torments
Claire with maddening voices and nearly
kills Sophia by touring her toward the
edge of the Tower with her mother's
voice thankfully Claire keeps her head
safe Sophia and gets both of them onto
the moving tram safely when Claire and
Sophia arrive at the castle they find a
sanctuary that's very similar to the one
that Mallory finds at the end of the
first film in the safe haven Sophia has
a tearful reunion with her mother and
Claire starts to receive treatment while
talking to a doctor about Sebastian and
the other Sears Claire realizes that the
creatures could be tapping into people's
grief and Trauma to control them they
can be reached you know they're still in
there somewhere it's at this point that
they discovered that the facility is
running tests on a Seer they captured to
find a cure but that's not all that's
here the survivors also have a creature
locked in a containment room and are
using it for tests leaving a foreboding
Heir over the finale of the movie one of
the biggest themes of bird box Barcelona
is how faith and Trauma are used as
destructive tools both by the creatures
Esteban and his followers Sebastian is
originally led to believe that the
creatures are angels sent by God to God
guide him in his path to save Humanity
but his eyes are opened and he sees that
their only desire is to orchestrate
cruel and painful deaths a big reason
that Sebastian and even Esteban are
turned into Sears is because of the
distinct grief and emptiness they share
Esteban has lost his faith by the time
he becomes a Seer and is desperate to
believe again while Sebastian is
suffering from immense grief stemming
from the loss of his family especially
Anna that's why she is an influential
spiritual guide for Sebastian and why
she becomes one of the keys to the
creature's control over him Claire even
has a conversation with a sanctuary
doctor highlighting how the creatures
use grief and emotion to Target
vulnerable people this depiction of the
creature's power touches on how faith
can be manipulated to justify terrible
acts and convince suffering people to
take dangerous paths Sebastian breaks
through the destructive sense of Faith
instilled by the creatures and it's
ultimately what makes him capable of
redemption while Sebastian's Redemption
symbolizes a thematic change of heart
for the character it also repres since a
major turning point for the franchise
his story shows that the Sears can be
cured for the first time we see that a
Seer can actually defy the creature's
power and act independently Claire tells
Sebastian's story to the people of the
sanctuary and it means that authors may
find ways to stop the seers however
Claire is far from the first to know
that Sears can be cured in the final
scene it's revealed that this new group
of survivors is trying to find a way to
cure Sears by testing the blood of one
who's been captured the tests aren't
just for curing Sears though as the
ending also implies that scientists are
looking for a way to fight the creatures
the survivors are also exposing animal
test subjects to the captured creature
in the hopes of finding an antidote of
sorts to their powers Sebastian saved
two people but perhaps This research
will make humans immune to the monster's
power and turn the tables against them
although Netflix has been pretty quiet
about Bird Box Barcelona leading up to
its release there has been some
discussion by lead star Mario Casas
about his character Sebastian in an
interview with MovieWeb causes not only
discussed his genuine love for the bird
Box franchise but also how Sebastian is
depicted as a complex and emotionally
compelling character he said I think it
was important to have a complex
character who should also have a very
deep emotional side and I think it's
something that hooks the audience I like
when a character is not always a hero
and he has many more layers and he has a
dark side and there's ambiguity this is
a perfect way to describe Sebastian's
character and his emotional story arc
Casas also went on to describe his views
of the creatures that tied to some of
the realizations made by Claire later in
the film revealing well I would say that
it has a lot more to do about trauma and
how these characters have this lack of
humanity I was thinking more of these
creatures as feelings of fear stress
loss sorrow his analysis of the
creatures as being more emotional and
mental entities rather than physical
ones fits perfectly into their depiction
in the world of bird box and how they
torment their victims and then they take
form based on us
or fears or grief or pain
the ending of bird box Barcelona leaves
the future of the franchise at an
interesting Crossroads there seems to be
more story to tell with these Barcelona
survivors a sequel could see Claire and
other members of the sanctuary in a
dangerous new fight for their lives if
the contained creature breaks out or
Claire could lead a group to another
sanctuary and continue to research how
to defeat the creatures of course the
bird Box Series has already expressed
interest in taking its formula around
the world so we could see another entry
set in a different country it would let
us see how other survivors in a
different setting are coping with this
dark new reality it could also lead to
more reveals about the creatures and
survivors and maybe that story could
build toward a larger world that would
see different characters come together
to take out the creatures for good the
possibilities are endless
with Bird Box Barcelona showing that
survivors are testing Sears and looking
for a way to defeat the creatures future
entries could Explain how other
countries are approaching Research into
the monsters it would be interesting to
see how other countries and cultures
have been affected by the creature's
arrival and their destructive abilities
with Barcelona we got more thematic
perspectives on religion and grief being
connected to the creatures new
international entries could touch on
other aspects of humanity that are being
twisted and manipulated well the
original Bird Box features a
star-studded cast and garnered a lot of
attention from subscribers when it
premiered it doesn't seem like we're
getting a continuation of that story
anytime soon Bird Box Barcelona
establishes itself as more of a
standalone spin-off set within the same
world and never directly referencing or
hinting at events or characters from the
first film but does that mean that we'll
never return to the world of the
original no but fans shouldn't expect a
true Bird Box sequel for a while there
haven't been many signs that a more
straightforward Bird Box 2 is in
development and the film's ending hints
more at a Barcelona sequel rather than
another American entry perhaps if the
franchise continues to touch on
different stories and characters from
around the globe it can all culminate in
a finale that teams up the survivors to
defeat the creatures for good but if a
traditional Bird Box 2 isn't the next
entry in this franchise and the story
continues branching out internationally
it's likely a return to the plot and
characters of the original isn't
happening
[Music]